nice guys finish first the second you
figure out that nice guys finish first
not last is the second good things will
happen in your life yes I think the way
we do business is going to be the way
everyone does business in the future
because it's going to be required to be
successful and if people can move on
that version faster which is more about
EQ than IQ then they'll be more
successful and that's what I want for
people not successful with money [__]
[__] money successful with contempt and
joy and happiness of course Money
Matters I don't diss money I'm an
entrepreneur I gotta buy the New York
Jets I'm not gonna buy the Jets with
hearts you can do both you can you can
be kind and it can be entrepreneurial it
doesn't it doesn't have to be rugged
love you see you love you see it by